leslie i typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems the band
has had a few
different names over the years we
started we were teddy bear suicide
but then we changed it to mouse rat uh
then we were god hates figs two doors
down
department of homeland obscurity then we
were three skin
just the tip flames for flames muscle
confusion
nothing rhymes with orange then
everything rhymes with orange
andy dwyer experience a.d and the d-bags
the andy andy andes
rad wagon five skin foreskin nothing
rhymes with
bloring death of a scam artist razor
dick
puppy pendulum awesome pendulum penis
pendulum and real suicide angel snack
uh jet black pope punch face champions
ninja dick
we went back to mouse rat and now we are
scarecrow boat
god when i hear myself say scarecrow
boat out loud i kind of hate it
every time i cleanse i can literally
feel the toxins leaving my body i know i
feel so much healthier
i've still got a full week to go before
the broth stage
pre-broth is an amazing stage it's when
you're most alert
good someone needs to be alert tonight
this snake juice is
basically rat poison everybody's wasted
you don't even know
one thing i didn't even say what they
gonna do she asked me the whole thing
and i didn't even do it once
i'm like an elephant okay if i walk into
a room it's like okay he's in there
turn this music down
[Music]
why are you naked oh well because of
what you said we're getting back
together
no we're not yes we are you should have
heard the super sexy stuff she was
saying to me
i said hey andy it's anne can we talk at
my house
how you said it you were like hey andy
it's anne can you
talk at my house oh my god you're such a
baby
oh literally big naked baby put clothes
on
you know what i should have seen this
coming yeah
i love cup gangs alice hates you
annie has herpes if what's your problem
my problem is you smell us
ben told you to finish the website and
if you don't do it i swear to god i'm
gonna murder you
in your sleep i know where you live 14th
street right i'm gonna get a melon
baller and scoop your eyes out and eat
them
and your congressman uncle's gonna have
to buy you a dog to drag your eyeless
face around do you understand me yes
do it okay
let's give the sucker a test drive
yeah so the idea is to make a fountain
that he can't do that to
ah that's good okay any ideas jerry
well i was thinking that we could put
this
cage thing around it okay that could
work
andy
thank you andy still good talk
full disclosure ann and i are
romantically intertwined oh god
so let's not be surprised if she fixed
my idea would you just go
dummy what's the best kind of water
fountain how about no water fountain
this is the voss water butler
by toomey at only 600 of that april
what's your idea
to go in that room and finish this book
oh really
yeah is it good yeah you're gonna stay
here and you're gonna help
donna do i look like i drink water why
do i want to build this park so bad
maybe because a pit filled with garbage
isn't the best that we can do in america
you know in russia they could pretend
that pit was a park
bring their kids down there hey vlad
uh look at these rocks let's pretend
they're potatoes
nikolai do you want to swim in the dirt
but not here okay cause we're a nation
of dreamers
and it is my dream to build a park
that i one day visit with my white house
staff on my birthday
and they say president nope this park is
awesome
now we understand why you are the first
female president of the united states
i vomited somewhere in this room
i don't remember where though but wait
you might want to check that drawer
stop pooping
you have to get up off the floor now as
far as my friend
i can't get through to the cable company
can you do something
like one based on truth based on
anything andy's just acting out scenes
from his favorite movies
so swayze runs boom tackles the guy off
the motorcycle dude's like your dad bro
comes at him swayze ducks
scissor kick slime the guy has sweetie's
head and he says i used to
guys like you in prison by the looks of
this guy this is not consensual sex
we're talking about we see bad guy had a
gun
the whole time he's like i'm gonna kill
you the old-fashioned way
swizzy's like not this time that subtext
he doesn't say that
bypasses the gun hooks the arm back to
the secret move he used before to kill
somebody he feels so bad about it but
this time he has to do it because of
self-defense
takes the esophagus out of the neck area
you can't eat
you'll starve to death and that is
roadhouse
what should i do next you guys uh
know anything about a guy named john
rambo open on
villagers being thrown out into a rice
field landmines blowing them up into
pieces
and that's how it ends i loved it
it's called babe and i know it sounds
corny talking pig
whatever you should all see it
i feel like i just did scrawny
christians
missionaries come to him and they're
like are you john rambo he's like
yeah no like we need you to take us
upriver he's like
it's a war zone up there and they're
like yeah we know we're gonna change
things
and he's like you burgered any weapons
they're like
of course not they do not change
anything go home
and then they come back in a rainstorm
this time he says
nope go home they go home again bottom
line they go up river
does not go well the floor is now open
for public comments oh here we go
thank you my name is garth blunden and i
object to your ridiculous proposal
uh the pawnee charter uh shall not be
changed
not today not ever wow a lot of passion
mr blunden thank you so much your
objection is noted and officially in the
record shall we proceed to
no no we shall not article seven section
three allows
for a citizen filibuster if i stand here
and refuse
to yield my time you are prohibited from
voting on the bill
that section defines buffalo meat as
acceptable currency is that the buffalo
meat one
uh i meant article three section seven
let the filibustering begin i would now
like to share
some ideas i have for j.j abrams seventh
chapter in the star wars saga panned
down from the twin sons
of tatooine we are now close on the
mouth of the sarlacc pit
after a beat the gloved mandalorian
armor
gauntlet of boba fett grabs onto the
sand outside the sarlacc
pit and the feared bounty hunter pulls
himself
from the maw of the sand beast then
he's right he can do this this is
exactly why we need to modernize these
laws
this kind of thing made sense when we
had council in a barn and there were 80
people in the town but
now this is nuts if he holds the reality
gem
that means he can jump from different
realities this
will be our link to the marvel universe
from the star wars universe
imagine those two going up against robot
chewbacca because that's gonna happen
after a beat luke says darth vader was
my father but ben kenobi was my master
and he cuts hannah blechter in half mr
blunden
i'm sorry are you leaving i thought we
had a meeting no we do it's just i think
it's a little chilly in here
are you okay your eyes are glassy oh my
god oh my
she's sick are you sick no yeah she's
sick
that's why i'm wearing this and misting
myself with hand sanitizer
i'm not sick i just have allergies okay
i took a claritin and i threw that up so
i took another one i threw that up
and then i took a third and it stayed
down i'm getting better
all right you're burning up you're
burning up what
i have to get out of here i have 2.8
body fat
my body's like a microchip a grain of
sand could destroy it
my body's a microchip
leslie go home no i can't i can't go
home i have to get ready for the chamber
of secrets
commerce if this meeting does not go
perfectly then the harvest festival is
going to be over before it began i
cannot go home
okay then who is your doctor ann's my
doctor
and she's the most beautiful nurse in
the world come on
oh girl now i'm hot now it's really hot
okay well that's your fever
leslie i typed your symptoms into the
thing up here and it says you could have
network connectivity problems
you